[Music]
space the final frontier since star trek
premiered in 1966 the trek universe has
been feeding our imagination with
villains among trek's baddies are some
of the most fun and memorable in popular
media from deceitful tricksters to
psychotic warlords here are the best
star trek villains ranked
as one of the youngest star trek series
with a much stronger focus on comedy the
animated star trek lower decks doesn't
boast a wealth of recurring villains
regardless one of the few ongoing bad
guys from the series is one of the
funniest and cleverest conceptions in
the entire trek franchise voiced by jack
mcbrayer of 30 rock fame the holographic
villain badgie is a hilarious and brutal
send-up of not only one of star trek's
most tired tropes but one of the most
famously annoying aspects of microsoft
software we first meet baji in season
one's terminal provocations when ensign
rutherford played by eugene cardero
introduces ensign devon attendee played
by noel wells to his holodeck training
program acting like the animated
paperclip clippy from microsoft office
and shaped like a starfleet badge badgy
at first seems eager to help rutherford
and tendy with whatever they need but
when an attack by alien scavengers
causes the holodeck to malfunction and
disengage the safety protocols baji
takes the opportunity to get vengeance
on the person he sees as his abusive
creator rutherford sharing such
clippy-like homicidal gems as
i'm gonna rip your eyes out and
here's a tip i'm going to burn your
hearts in a fire
badgy pursues rutherford and tendy
across holographic landscapes until
rutherford figures out a way to defeat
him baji makes a second appearance in
the season one finale and we hope we'll
be seeing plenty more of him in the
future
kurtwood smith has made a number of tv
and film appearances in the star trek
franchise but none of his characters are
as chilling and sympathetic as the
brilliant scientist anorex from season 4
of star trek voyager he never reappeared
after the two-parter year of hell but he
made enough of an impression to earn a
spot on the list part of a race known as
the krenim anorex begins his cursed
quest by seeking to restore his people's
once expansive empire to power to this
end he develops a temporal weapon called
the weaponship which he uses to wipe out
other species he doesn't just kill them
he erases them from time while his
attempts do restore more and more of the
krenim imperium the restoration of a
single colony eludes him every time the
colony of kiana prime where anorexis
wife children and grandchildren lived
until his actions unintentionally erased
them as such he and his restless crew
protected from the time space continuum
within their ship have continued like
this for two centuries committing
genocide again and again to feed the
obsession of captain who's convinced
time itself is claiming vengeance upon
him when i tell you
the time has moved
a disposition to be intuited
i'm not speaking metaphorically
though he only appeared in two episodes
anorex is one of the most quietly
horrifying and tragic villains in the
entire track franchise
few star trek villains simultaneously
embody the sophistication shakespearean
nobility and ruthlessness of the late
christopher plummer's general chang
plummer was a fitting choice not only
because of his acting chops but because
he was an important part of william
shatner's career a decade before shatner
assumed the role of captain kirk he was
plummer's understudy in a 1956
production of henry v chang appears
exclusively in the final film of the
movie saga featuring the original series
crew
1991's star trek vi the undiscovered
country chang is one of the architects
of an alliance between rogue elements of
the federation the klingon empire and
the romulan empire who are unwilling to
see a lasting peace between earth and
kronos chang plays a large part in the
framing of captain kirk and dr mccoy for
the assassination of klingon chancellor
gorka he then prosecutes them in the
unforgiving klingon court and towards
the end of the film he comes close to
destroying both the enterprise and the
excelsior with his prototype bird of
prey while chang is ultimately
unsuccessful he exudes a singular
presence from start to finish plummer is
particularly impressive when he and the
rest of gorkhan's entourage are leaving
the enterprise after a diplomatic dinner
despite not saying a single overtly
threatening word or making any hostile
gesture his body language and facial
expressions tell you everything you need
to know in the scene that chang is eager
to be the man who defeats kirk in battle
the android data is easily one of the
fan favorite characters from star trek
the next generation but one of the
downsides to portraying this crew member
is that aside from instances where
something causes data's programming to
go haywire the emotional spectrum that
actor brent spiner gets to play with is
fairly limited that changes after the
season one introduction of data's evil
brother lore in
datalore unlike data lore is gifted with
human emotions but unfortunately he
received them long before dr noonyan
soon had truly learned how to properly
program them as a result lore is
unstable and treacherous it's eventually
discovered that lore was the one who
summoned the powerful crystal entity
that destroyed all human life on omicron
theta the planet upon which both
androids were discovered
after lore is reassembled he deactivates
data and assumes his identity and
attempt to feed the crew of the
enterprise to the crystal entity and in
his final appearance the two-part
descent which bridges the sixth and
seventh seasons he becomes something of
a cult leader to a group of borg who
liberated themselves from the collective
as humorous as he is evil lore is one of
the most fun villains to show up on the
next generation at the same time his
appearances often pack an emotional
punch since the evil android remains one
of the few creatures data can call
family
first appearing in the season 4 tng
episode reunion gauran isn't always a
villain he's introduced as one of the
two contenders for the klingon
chancellorship which is a title he
eventually achieves throughout tng
gauran is for the most part more of a
neutral character pursuing his own
agenda this changes once tng ends and
gauran becomes a recurring character on
star trek deep space nine his first ds9
appearance is in season three's the
house of cork but gauran doesn't become
an important part of the show's serial
drama until michael dorn's wharf joins
the series in the season 4 premiere the
way of the warrior while still
expressing the trademark klingon passion
for battle gauran is portrayed more as
an opportunistic politician on ds9 he
uses the threat of the dominion to
reignite his people's warlike tendencies
in order to spur an invasion of
cardassia and later a new war with the
federation during the epic war storyline
in the show's final season gauran
purposely wastes the lives of his
warriors by sending the forces of
general martok who he sees as a
political rival to fight the battles
they can't win as a means of humiliation
played expertly by robert o'reilly in
all of his appearances gauran is an
unforgettable klingon villain with some
of the craziest eyes you'll ever see
for most of star trek discovery's
inaugural season jason isaacs captain
gabriel lorca commands the eponymous
vessel while he has a mysterious heir
early in the series you're convinced
he's the real deal because of his
leadership skills and what appears to be
an unwavering dedication to his crew
that changes after the discovery winds
up in the mirror universe toward the end
of the episode into the forest i go for
most of the time the crew is in the
strange brutal reality no one seems to
know exactly how they got there it isn't
until the third to last episode of the
season vaulting ambition that we learn
gabriel lorca is a mirror universe
native having switched places with his
prime counterpart before the events of
the series lorca sees the potential of
discovery's spore drive to bring him
back home so he can continue his
rebellion against emperor philippa
giorgio
just the fact that lurka is able to pull
the wool over so many viewers eyes is
enough to secure him a spot on this list
but isaac's superb acting and the
layered conception of the character
earns the accolades all on their own
lorca is able to fool us precisely
because he isn't simply a mustache
twirling bad guy while he's using the
discovery crew for his own ends he bears
no ill will toward them and in some ways
the respect and care he shows for them
is genuine until it isn't i couldn't
have imagined but lorca was an impostor
from an alternate universe was not the
most obvious conclusion
we were all deceived
a lot of fans would balk at the idea of
having the andorian commander shrand
being labeled a villain portrayed by
jeffrey combs shran who is fiercely
loyal to his people was introduced in
star trek enterprise's first season we
meet shran in an episode titled the
andorian incident where he leads a squad
of his blue skinned brethren in the
violent takeover of a vulcan monastery
shrand and the other andorians come off
as nothing more than paranoid and
xenophobic bullies but despite their
thuggish behavior captain archer
discovers they're right about the
monastery being a cover for a vulcan
facility that monitors the andorians
when archer exposes the truth he earns
an uneasy ally in sran shran comes to
the aid of archer and the enterprise on
more than one occasion in season three
shran bails the heroes out twice
including the final battle to save earth
from the zindi's doomsday weapon but
there's always volatility working under
shiran's surface threatening to once
more put him at odds with archer and his
crew it happens for example in season
4's united when trans stubborn refusal
to give the telerites the benefit of the
doubt leads to archer challenging him to
a death duel
for the most part christopher lloyd's
most famous characters like doc brown in
the back to the future series aren't
particularly intimidating so it's a
testament to the actor's range that he
performed so well as the klingon
commander krug in 1984's star trek iii
the search for spock when krug learns of
starfleet's secret genesis project meant
to instantly turn lifeless celestial
bodies into habitable planets he means
to seize it as a doomsday weapon for the
klingon empire in the process he orders
the killing of captain kirk's son a
death that scars kirk for years in many
ways krug is the first example of the
kind of klingon we know and love today
while their new look is shown briefly in
1979 star trek the motion picture it
isn't until krug that we get to see a
fully fleshed out performance while the
klingons were always warlike krug and
his crew are more brutish than their
predecessors in the original series
locking himself in a death grip with an
alien beast just for fun and going mono
amano with kirk as genesis is in its
explosive death throes krug gives us a
portrayal of what remains one of the
most potent examples of the klingon
passion for combat
you don't find a lot of trek villains
wearing starfleet uniforms after all the
desire to join starfleet is usually
accompanied by a drive to uphold the
values of the united federation of
planets but one notable exception is
lieutenant commander michael eddington
played by kenneth marshall introduced in
ds9 season 3 premiere eddington starts
out as an officer who appears to be
overly concerned with promotion and more
than willing to turn in the heroes of
ds9 if they dare disobey their starfleet
superiors toward the end of season 4 we
learn eddington's seemingly tireless
devotion to starfleet is a ruse in the
episode for the cause eddington tricks
most of ds9's command crew away from the
station and in their absence steals a
shipment of industrial replicators he
then reveals himself as a member of the
maquis a group of violent rebels who
oppose the federation's treaty with
cardassia
the very fact that eddington is able to
trick benjamin cisco played by avery
brooks makes the starfleet's commander
turned captain obsessed with capturing
the traitor he's one of the few villains
capable of getting so thoroughly under a
captain's skin to the point where said
captain actually humors some rather
questionable tactics and apprehension
and if it takes me the rest of my life i
will see you standing before a court
martial that'll break you
the flamboyant and deceptive harry mudd
is one of the few named antagonists from
the original series to enjoy a second
appearance played by roger c carmel he
first shows up in season one's muds
women trying to sell women like cattle
and using an illegal drug to render them
physically irresistible later in season
two's i mud the con man gives up the
enterprise screw to a group of androids
with dreams of galactic conquest carmel
returned to voice his famous crook in an
episode of star trek the animated series
called mud's passion in the episode he
runs foul of the enterprise once more
after attempting to con the inhabitants
of an alien planet into believing he
could sell them starfleet academy that
wouldn't be the end of mud rayne wilson
plays a more vicious version of harry
mudd in star trek discovery's first
season captain lorca meets mud in the
episode choose your pain where they're
both prisoners of the klingons lorca and
lieutenant ash tyler leave mud behind
after they escape the klingons and the
con man gets revenge with a plot
involving a time manipulation device in
the episode magic to make the sanest man
go mad
one of the most popular pieces of trek
mythology introduced in ds9 is the
clandestine organization section 31 and
william sadler's brilliant performance
as luther sloan the director of section
31 during the events of ds9 makes him
one of the most memorable villains
suspecting dr bashir played by alexander
siddig of being an unwitting spy for the
dominion sloan first shows up on ds9
using a holodeck to find out the truth
he subjects bashir to an elaborate
illusion in which all of his friends on
ds9 turn their backs on him once beshear
discovers the truth sloan is convinced
of his innocence and offers him a
position with section 31 despite
beshear's clear refusal sloan returns to
use the doctor in a covert operation
involving the infiltration of the
romulan empire toward the end of the
series we learned sloan is behind the
poisoning of odo and all of his fellow
changelings with a deadly plague sloan
is ruthless cunning and mysterious but
he's surprisingly sympathetic he's aware
of the hypocrisy of betraying the
federation's core values in order to
protect it yet he still believes in what
he's doing and has no ill will towards
bashir for despising him he sees bashir
as exactly the kind of man he was born
to protect even if safeguarding him
earns him nothing but bashir's disgust
introduced in the original series the
mirror universe is an alternate
dimension where the federation is
replaced by the tyrannical terran empire
rather than living by values like
tolerance diplomacy and discovery the
terence are a brutal people who believe
in conquest and cruelty in the ds9
episode crossover dr bashir and major
kira played by nana visitor find
themselves in the alternate universe
where they learn that since the events
of the original series the terran empire
has been conquered by the klingon
cardassian alliance terence have become
a slave race and ds9 retaining its
original cardassian name tariq noor is
led by intended kira intended kira is
the cold-blooded counterpart to major
kira and the character gives visitor a
chance to show us her acting range aside
from sharing natural leadership
qualities intended kira is a wild
departure from major kira she's
seductive with an unapologetically
endless appetite for pleasure using
cisco a pirate in the mirror universe as
her personal plaything she's as vicious
as any of the kardashians or klingons
under her command and deceptively
sadistic sometimes acting as if she's
about to absolve her victims before
ordering their executions intended kira
was far too much fun for just a single
ds9 episode so she became a recurring
villain
you hear a lot about villains you love
to hate but then there are villains you
just straight up hate kai win is
definitely one of the latter luis
fletcher plays win on ds9 beginning as
an ambitious medic of a rigid religious
order on bajor wynn is a slippery and
manipulative vedic working behind the
scenes in coup and assassination
attempts her actions she claims are
always at the service of the wormhole
dwelling aliens which majorans worship
and call the prophets yet it seems she's
always working towards her own ascension
in the ranks of bajor's clergy she
succeeds in becoming bajor's spiritual
leader the kai but by the end of the
series her jealousy towards ben cisco
her seduction by goldikott and her anger
towards the prophets lead her to abandon
her religion and follow the devilish
parades
wynn is one of the most interesting and
complex villains in all of trek her
downfall is tragic in the most classic
sense of the word once she wins the
title of kai rather than simply basking
in her power as we expect she seems to
genuinely want to help her people the
problem is of course she also seems to
fully believe that the ends justify any
and all means what if you could
genetically engineer a race to be
equally cutting leaders and diplomats in
the most hostile of situations what you
would come up with might look a lot like
the vorta which is the dominion's
lieutenant race that leads hordes of
brutal gemhadar while being completely
subservient to the founders and of the
vorta we meet on ds9 none is more
memorable than jeffrey combs weiyou
while weiyoun dies at the end of his
first appearance in season 4's to the
death the villain was just too good to
discard entirely so it was decided that
the founders keep clones of the vorta
constantly at the ready complete with
the memories of their predecessors as
the head of the dominion's military
presence in the alpha quadrant weion
frequently shows up in the last two
seasons of ds9 and he steals every scene
he's in he's dishonest and manipulative
without shame ready to shift from
intimidating to conciliatory at a
moment's notice in scenes with
politically influential ds9 characters
like ben cisco and gul dukat wein uses
conversation like a deadly evasive
weapon always adapting to his
counterparts mood with everything from
wrath to abject apology he lies so
easily that you wonder whether or not
weiyu knows or even cares what's true or
false
any list of best star trek villains that
doesn't include ricardo montalban's khan
needs to delete everything and start
over first appearing in the original
series episode space seed khan is a
genetically enhanced despot who ruled
over a quarter of the earth before
escaping the eugenic wars with 84 of his
followers the enterprise crew regrets
waking khan and his people from
suspended animation once they take over
the ship while khan is a fun villain in
his first appearance his appeal doesn't
reach full bloom until 1982's star trek
ii the wrath of khan which is arguably
the best star trek movie blaming kirk
for the tragedies that have befallen him
since they crossed paths years earlier
khan and his followers take over the uss
reliant and wage war on the enterprise
while khan's followers believe they're
using the stolen federation property for
power and prosperity it's soon clear
their leader is willing to sacrifice
everything including his own life and
theirs to get revenge on kirk i mean to
avenge myself upon you admiral
i've deprived your shape of power and
when i swing around i mean to deprive
you of your life
through montalban khan becomes the
absolute embodiment of all consuming
vengeance the villain regularly either
paraphrases or directly quotes lines
from herman melville's novel moby dick
and just as captain ahab is obsessed
with destroying the titular whale khan
ultimately has no purpose left but
vengeance against kirk
in tng's cue who episode the borg one of
the federation's deadliest enemies are
introduced the cybernetic zombie-like
hive-minded baddies kill with impunity
however their goal is not just to kill
but to assimilate the technology and
biology of other intelligent species
into their collective in a quest for
ultimate perfection there are no
individuals within the borg collective
but in 1996's star trek first contact
were introduced to the borg queen the
living embodiment of the collective's
will the borg queen does something you
wouldn't think possible with the borg
she makes them sexy in fact she spends
most of her scenes in first contact
seducing data with promises of pleasures
he's never been capable of fully
experiencing but she's far from just a
temptress particularly in her subsequent
appearances in star trek voyager the
borah queen played by both alice krieg
and suzanne thompson at different points
conveys the singular horror of being
confronted by a being who is in her own
words one who is many speaking to looper
in early 2020 krieg shared interesting
insights about playing the cybernetic
villain including how the character came
to be krieg explained i think she was an
entity that happened at the moment of
creation and she's always been that and
she always will be and it's entirely
abnormal
perhaps no other single villain has
appeared in as many star trek series is
john de lancie's all-powerful q showing
up for the premiere of tng its finale
and a bunch of fun episodes in between q
is a mischievous god-like being who
defies definition he would eventually
come to harass voyager's captain janeway
almost as much as he did picard along
with brief but memorable appearances on
ds9 and star trek lower decks hilarious
and carefree q is so popular that it
might be a problem for some fans to even
call him a villain but while he isn't
wholly evil he's certainly a villain in
the sense that when he shows up he's
almost always an antagonist while he
usually reverses any direct harm he
inflicts upon humans he couldn't care
less about those who are lost indirectly
such as the enterprise crew members
killed by the borg in the episode cue
who whether you see him as a good guy or
a bad guy delancey's portrayal of the
trickster is one of the most delightful
parts of tng and voyager after all
without him we'd never see a mariachi
band on the enterprise bridge we'd never
see gainen plunge a fork into a dude's
hand and most importantly we'd never see
the enterprise crew in sherwood forest
get out of my chair
and i was hoping for something more
along the lines of welcome back hugh
it's a pleasure to see you again my old
friend
one of the aspects where ds9 excels over
other trek series is that its serialized
storytelling allows its characters to
evolve and you can see this evolution
clearly in the cardassian tyrant
golducot formerly the prefect of bajor
during its occupation ducat is none too
happy to find a human sitting in his old
office in ds9's premiere episode this
fixation on cisco and his crushing sense
of inadequacy grow over the course of
the series to the point where it
suffocates him the ducats we meet in
ds9's premiere isn't the ducat we see in
its finale a classic cardassian ducats
spends the first few seasons of ds9
working towards the goal of once again
ruling over the people of bajor he's not
only unwilling to face the atrocities he
committed but he's so delusional that he
resents the bajorans for refusing to
honor him with statues and plaques
for a time he's something of an ally to
the ds9 crew but when the dominion gives
him an opportunity to seize control over
all of cardassia he becomes the alpha
quadrant's most feared warlord before
the end of the series he goes from
conqueror to madman madman to cult
leader and from cult leader to the
powerful vessel of the paw wraiths the
prophet's destructive adversaries
wonderfully portrayed by mark alimo
ducat is ultimately the most complex
believable and twisted villain in all of
star trek
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
star trek are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]